I'm happy that I can put a smile on
someone's face when they're eating a
pastry I created hi I'm June
today I'm making chiffon cake I am a
pastry chef had proof bakery in Los
Angeles chiffon cake is a very classic
light cake it's like angel food cake
virgin wash so it's very light very nice
to eat especially on a summer time I
moved from the Philippines to the US
here in Los Angeles when I was 20 and I
instantly went to the culinary school
and the rest is history it's special
because it's the first cake I learned
from my mother and I was very excited
about it and very technique-driven cake
and I'm happy that I learned it from her
I make this cake usually where
somebody's birthday at home or a cousin
so everybody likes this cake making
meringue can be very difficult if we
don't understand the technicality of it
we wanted to make sure that after we
whip it we have a nice glossy texture of
fine texture in it and there's no pieces
of sugar when you're incorporating the
base and the meringue that you made we
want to do two folding techniques so
you're not popping all the air pockets
that you create it into the meringue
because that's what makes the cake rises
as you bake we don't use eggs in our
buttercream we use butter evaporated
milk and sugar because eggs are pretty
pricey back in Manila where I grew up
only use it in the cakes that we bake
and then the buttercream is just use
butter sugar and milk I knew I was gay
when I was younger I knew it right away
that was different I was different from
the other boys that I see the
neighborhood the different from the boys
that I see in school but I didn't come
out till I was 22 I was already here in
Los Angeles with my family and that's
when I decided to come out I pretty much
grew up in church there was a huge
battle between what I'm feeling and who
I am and my religious background so it
was hard for me to accept who I really
am in the beginning when I started
working in the kitchens it was hard you
know I see my being gay was a downfall
as a weakness but then I realized no
it's not it's my power in the end you
would earn
spec's because she would show what you
can do it would see what you can do and
you just have to pretty much prove
yourself every day and not stop but I
tell most of my co-workers this not to
stop learning and to always be accepting
of criticisms it's pretty much how you
will learn and grow is accepting that
and learning from that and I still
learned until now even though I've been
in the business for a while every time I
come to work I still learn something new
for young people or any person that's
gay and wanted to be a chef I mean just
be yourself you don't have to hide
anything be humble and just be kind
if anybody listening to this and you're
struggling and coming out to anybody to
your parents or to your loved ones to
your to your friends take your time it
will happen when you're ready do not
force yourself to come out I know it's
hard
trust your feeling there are better
things after when you come out oh oh yes
[Music]